i always wondered about that day like
for you like was there anything about
that day that people don't know like
are you like are you going i'm gonna
make history today or no you know what i
mean like
i think the misconception is that
there's definitely there there are um
there's a lot of folklore about that but
what is the craziest thing you've heard
that is just not true
oh well there's this
whole narrative someone
i planned the whole thing i kept other
skaters out of it
it was you know everything was leading
towards that moment and if you really
look at the history of skating
in that year
there were those trick events in other
events yeah and i was trying nine
hundreds other skaters were trying nine
hundreds
we couldn't do it but i never i never
relied on that so i always had a
strategy where i would have a trick in
mind
that i knew would probably place well
that i haven't done or that i've only
done a couple times and that was my
strategy for the best tricks so when we
went to the x games they they chose the
people who had done well in all the best
trick events so anyone that
didn't place
maybe was just trying 900 to make it
they weren't chosen
because they weren't placing well you
got to land something you got a person
right but also
in the um
when it came to the x games
the the best trick events i think that
that's the misperception is that they
were just after afterthoughts
it was like we're going to have the
contest and and the contest happened and
that was the big event now let's move
around you guys you got 20 minutes try
stuff yeah and it was just a bail fest
and people weren't even sticking around
for it
because maybe you saw one or two tricks
landed but yeah it was only for the
hardcore skaters so when when they did x
games our attitude was the same was like
oh
they're not going to air it
because we're just going to be falling
so
going into it
i had one trick in mind um which was a
varial 720 so it's a 720 spin with my
body and then i turn my board in extra
180. so basically my board is a 900 and
my body is 720 right
that was literally my best trick i'd
done it once before
and i didn't know if i could even make
it in that time right
i made it
like 10 minutes in
and then that was it like so you have
one in the bag that was my best trick
now it's time to have fun well i didn't
even have a plan yeah and uh the
announcer uh dave duncan who i love
still is announcing uh skate events
he's he's like oh maybe we're gonna see
that 900.
and so i i thought all right i'll try
one for the crowd it was more like oh
here's here's what it looks like here's
an attempt yeah and then after i think
my second or third attempt
it was really consistent and i was
spotting the landing and i was i thought
well just try to landed
to break a rib again so what
that was that was the craziest mindset
to me if i break a rib again so what
there's like i mean if you're ever gonna
you're gonna
land something or try something it's in
that moment yeah yeah it's it's the most
widely the biggest the biggest venue
we've ever had
the biggest viewership and not in
viewership just more like the most
exciting right yeah yeah and no one had
built i mean i i heard my friend say
recently like i was always bummed that
the espn got them and it wasn't like an
escape skate only event
and i said well at that time no one
could have afforded to build a ramp
like that was the best ramp we ever had
yeah and that's i credit that as much as
anything yeah
and what was so specific about it it was
just built really well it was really
solid they had the money and the needs
and so
the when you back then when you skate
uh wooden ramps homemade ramps there was
a lot of flaws there were you know one
wall was this one really yeah or the
coping was bad or you know so you had to
find the pockets of the ramp that were
good
and that was more what you spent your
time doing
um was making the ramp work for you and
then this ramp was like perfection yeah
it's as perfect as it could be back then
yeah that's interesting like you hear
that with a basketball like that there's
dead spots in the boston yeah the old
guard oh yeah yeah and they would force
like celtics defenders would force
players there to get steals yeah there's
just like old wood or stuff that hasn't
been put down and like you don't even
think about that a billion dollar
business that that could exist like in
these venues but i guess especially if
you're doing these like local events
back in the day there's they just got to
hire somebody everything was terrible so
we we just made it work yeah
and now i now i have what i consider a
perfect
which is
which actually makes it hard because
when i go out and skate other stuff
oh man everything is a struggle and i
was just used to trash or right and then
you became awesome because you were
working on the worst [ __ ]
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah why do you
have that gap in your ramp
uh uh because it was originally for um
that ramp was for the hachin
and so what the hotjam was my tour that
i told you that was built for that okay
and so we had a big ramp that was i
think about 30 feet high
that would go through that gap and then
we would jump the whole length
oh [ __ ] so that's what that's
okay and then you just kept the gap
yeah i mean it poses its punch i mean it
looks crazy on video
yeah
it looks terrifying it uh
it can go horribly wrong have you seen
somebody
yeah yeah
have you ever yeah
no
i i know exactly
where to be where to like there's
there's a certain there's a certain
angle
to getting over it and if you're on that
angle even if you're gonna fall you're
gonna
make it the other side yeah yeah it's
more that people who don't skate the
ramp that much and they don't realize
the opposing wall what they're doing
i've seen people just
go through it like where you know they
come up oh there's no wall
there's a uh
do you remember the the skier his name
was bodie miller yeah he said something
once and it kind of like blew my mind a
little bit and he was like um i'm not
better than these guys skill wise but
i'm willing to take more risk and the
guy kind of like pushed him on it he
goes like
i'm going to take a harder line and i'm
going to put my life on the line more
than the average person will
and uh
i always wonder like how much of that
like is
how much of that lends itself to the
success of somebody who's doing these
these extreme sports like do you know
certain guys that are more skilled but
they just don't have the balls you don't
have to say their names but like do you
ever look at certain guys oh man if he
would really throw it he could be yeah
sure
you see it a lot and
it's hard to
be
on the sidelines wanting to push them
into it
like you can't be more excited for
someone's career
than they are yeah
um but but a lot of but often
i'll see something and
and sort of help someone unlock it
because i can see that they would be
capable of this
and they're just not really pushing it
or haven't even thought oh maybe i could
take it this other way and i've
definitely helped a few people
get to a certain trick or a certain
technique because they just didn't see
it in themselves
um but other times i've seen i've seen
like the most raw talent go to waste
just because they didn't have the
they just don't have a drive yeah man
it's
yeah it's just it's kind of crazy you
need to be able to risk it
it's a
it's just something you can't see like i
i
often use an example uh
lizzie armanto who's on our team
she's it's awesome uh
bowl skater or she skates birds
sometimes
um but she did she did our full
lubricant yeah
and
that
her approach and the way
the way that she ended up doing it she
tried i mean
usually when we do it it's this whole
production we've got all these pads
learning the pads and then we start
removing pads to get closer
when when when she finally was ready for
it
and there were no pads
she ended up falling like four or five
times
but managed to to get out yeah you know
these like like there's there's a photo
of her knee sliding at 12 o'clock wow so
upside down fully fully upside down off
her board and then sliding around
and
any one of her falls would have would
have driven someone away like i'm not
doing this this is too gnarly she just
kept an end
and yes we're giving her pointers along
the way those of us who've done it but
at some point it's on her yeah and and i
try to tell people that like you cannot
teach that kind of grit for so well yeah
yeah yeah that's just she just has that
yeah and i feel like there's a certain
faction of skaters they just have that
it doesn't matter what
it doesn't matter what how they were
guided through
it just came with it yeah yeah there is
that like i don't want to call it like
uh
insanity but like that drive that the
greats have it exists in the same way
but you really need it like you can get
by with like good fundamentals in a
sport that's not as dangerous
sure you know what i mean like that with
really good fundamentals and enough size
can exist in the nba and you can have
some mid-level contracts for a while
like they can you you're six nine you're
going to be in the moa yeah
but if you actually want to be one of
the greats you have to have that [ __ ]
killer thing yeah that's crazy have you
seen the video of nigel houston doing
the grind on the freeway
or like yeah grind on like his balcony
yeah like overlooking like a 30-story
drop oh yeah and he'll just like ollie
pop up 50-50 then jump off
yeah that's the east of his skills
yeah right but the but the being able to
overcome the fear of like looking out by
far
yeah it's like the free accounting guy
what's his name alex
yeah you know just do you think you have
some of that maybe
like yeah i like i jumped up i jumped
between two seven seven-story buildings
downtown l.a wow i never i never
imagined that it wasn't gonna work
you know i think that's what it is when
you when you're in when you're in that
kind of mode and you're and you're
presented with that sort of
stunt or or challenge
you never think like
oh it's all terrible because that's what
that's what's going to happen that's the
only thing i think yeah what about that
what does that say about me
that's why you weren't there that day
jumping in with them there you go 100
i'll be on the elevator but do you think
do you think about that when you're on
stage
on stage beforehand i definitely think
about it really when you're up there you
you can't really think about yeah you're
just so locked in at that moment yeah
it's like when they say if you drive a
race car wherever your eyes go that's
where you're gonna go yeah yeah when
you're when you're skating if you think
like oh my god what if i if i sketch out
what if i that's what if i don't grab
that snap it's almost liberating for me
before i get on stage should be like
yeah my bum
let's hope i don't bomb or something
just to like acknowledge the thing and
then it's like all right what happens it
happens you keep going but that's it
like i'll say to people if they're like
hey you're great i'm looking for i hope
i don't bomb and then i just say it to
everybody like hey this could happen
let's just go do it it's just weird it
makes me it takes it i think it's more
when people go down the rabbit hole of
visualizing what does that look like oh
yeah yeah the bombing and the
embarrassment the heat yeah me saying it
just like okay acknowledge it now it's
done yeah yeah oh boy sweat boy sounds
like vietnam
yeah bombing is a physical experience it
really is like your body like i would
distinctly remember like drips of sweat
rolling down my back yes
yes and like
you get so quiet i was like can they
hear the sweat dripping
when the bomb first starts and you feel
it here yeah and then you're like oh
[ __ ] here it comes down the back
i know it's coming